hello and welcome to this video playing
card start and i got totally killed with
the trompe last game so i think he plays
at c5 variation against against quincy
tune let's see you get to get the same
ish going again maybe haven't done that
for quite a while check
yeah this is this stuff I often have
problems with I cannot really say why I
mean I'm playing this the same is
playing the same ish variation mostly
but yeah it's not like a no waiter all
that well but that I often have issues
okay now i feel reasonably reasonably
happy again
okay let's see what happens here on the
kingside maybe you can take on deform
and then grab see form
whoa okay so strong medicine when one
reason why this very strong medicine is
g6 this kind of thing but this is also
something that looks and it's just it
just grateful white which is probably a
huge understatement if you check with
four pieces a group night Bishop each
slab resign yes okay it's that's okay it
would have been nice to see it played
out but this is like crazy well the
engine is giving a funny evaluation plus
120 so it has some meter some some kind
of make it on the horizon okay so it was
a nice comeback of the same ish let's
get on it ok this one here here here the
move that are always concerned about is
this equal move this has been played
against me and I had issues definitely
because the c-4 porn something like that
i mean this is basically gone which is
pretty much standard in this opening
that you will lose this at some point
but when i played this in earlier games
I didn't really get much in terms of
compensation for it I don't know when
something like this see canisters it's
always listened
of course I can go for something like
you with f3e but it never felt totally
convincing to me yeah okay the same
which is not something that is a huge
part of my white rope or twine over the
board chest it's just something that I
would play on and off like once every
every couple of years but it's still us
concerning ok now I'm happy because you
for now is played by me and he cannot
push it for himself so this is this i'm
reasonably happy with and I always like
to get the pin in because it's very
difficult for black to unpin this
without age six and g5 and that is by
far not ideal yeah 95 and then f4 was
coming yeah g5 is the is the interesting
is the movie probably should play
leading to a typical very sharp plane i
don't think i can get sacrifice stuff so
probably bishop back and yeah what now
if he goes night 85 I'm going here for
Knight to f5 so I mean something
something like that for example it's
always going to be very decent
compensation for white ok we went here
and this is getting very hairy now I'm
threatening to take on e5 and form for
this I expected him to take and then I
did not quite know how to do it
precisely if I just recapture admits it
looks very nice him and he basically has
to tape on c4 now I think maybe with
this and then
then the question is what now can I go
if I've immediately then then he
actually has a tactically base defense I
mean this is still looking very
dangerous to be honest but maybe not
losing the engine doesn't see a win for
wide engine gives this which is not the
most natural move ever to play in a
blitz game yeah it prepares e5 and here
engine gives why the Whitney advanced
activity file id super dangerous fam
they ok this is this is just losing the
house attacking with absolutely
everything is a bit much so what is this
main line of the engine let's see what
what does this want to do Queen to e7
Teague's Queenie six route f6 the
engines lie needing to have made it a
couple of moves yeah ok they're the same
she keeps claiming victims but it is
also risky for white ok well thanks for
watching